Delivering the future.
Little robots taking parcels and groceries to the front door due to starting Greenwich, London next year.
Up until now, the unpredictable complexity of the real world,
infinite variety of hazards and obstacles meant the last mile of delivery needed a human.
Not, it seems, any more. Thanks very much.
It's us waiting around at home in a five-hour delivery window. We have to take a day off work.
It's so time-consuming and such a waste.
Robotics and technology in the current day right now can solve those problems. So that's what we're doing.
There's no doubt that this coming wave of automation, of artificial intelligence and robots like this one,
is going to deliver huge advantages to society. It's going to transform our lives, make them more convenient.
The question is, is it also going to bring us some problems that society is going to struggle to cope with,
not least, more inequality?
This is what could happen. With delivery bots, driverless vans, warehouse robots and online retailing,
it's possible for a tiny number of people to sew up an entire market that once employed hundreds of thousands or even millions.
The few can get fabulously rich. As for the rest,
in previous eras of job destruction, when mechanization chased farm workers off the land,
it also created new and better-paid jobs in the towns and cities.
And when muscle work disappeared, we moved into brain work.
But soon, the machines will not only be stronger than us, but smarter too.
Some new jobs will be created. These are robot handlers ready to take control if one of the delivery robots gets into trouble.
The real worry is about how many of these new jobs there are going to be.
One study estimates that 35% of UK jobs will be automated away in 10 to 20 years' time,
and that jobs that pay under £30,000 a year are five times more at risk from automation than jobs that pay above £100,000.
Research by McKinsey's has warned that this transformation is happening 10 times faster and at 300 times the scale of the Industrial Revolution.
Or, in other words, with 3,000 times the impact of the changes that transform the Victorian world.
These sculptures are perhaps a good metaphor for how most politicians have reacted to the challenge until now.